uh this is one of the shadiest elections
in a very long time that we had on
november eighth earlier this month i
talked to you already about the exit
poll reported vote discrepancies in
Donald Trump's favor in 23 of 28 states
I've also talked to you about the
discrepancies in specific precincts
where you compared electronic voting
machine results to counties that don't
use those machines and again those were
in Trump's favor in some very key and
close states very strange discrepancies
and in the background of this we've got
Russian influence in the election we
have voter suppression which saw many
voters turned away the latter of which
undeniably impacted the results of this
election so what's the basis of this
situation well some computer scientists
have been pointing out what they call
irregularities in some states that in
their view warrant a recount this
includes Wisconsin and Michigan and
Pennsylvania and they're using the words
manipulated or hacked let's look at some
of the claims that are at least being
made in Wisconsin by these computer
scientists number one they make a claim
that hillary clinton received seven
percent fewer votes in counties using
optical scanners and paper ballots this
implies the possibility of 30,000 votes
having been denied to hillary clinton
and you'll remember that hillary clinton
lost wisconsin by only 27,000 votes now
this doesn't even include the number of
votes that jill stein receive there and
the particular importance of those votes
in the context of the allegations made
by these computer scientists now this
has led to Jill Stein actually raising
millions of dollars for the recounts the
recount paperwork was filed in Wisconsin
on Friday and that recount is actually
expected to start near the end of this
week now Hillary Clinton's campaign
the weekend joined the jill stein
campaign in pushing for some of these
recounts in multiple states Hillary
Clinton's attorney actually said the
campaign is not currently contesting the
results themselves but they are
participating in the recount to quote
ensure that it is fair to all sides so
how would this have worked if it is
indeed hacking that we're talking about
well there's an article on medium by
Alex Halderman professor professor of
computer science at the University of
Michigan and in terms of how it could be
done haldimand Halderman says you don't
have to look further than look the DNC
email system was hacked John Podesta
zeeeee email was hacked we've seen
infiltration of voter registration
systems in Illinois and Arizona where
voter data was stolen and we have
evidence that hackers tried to breach
election offices in several other key
states so we don't really have to look
far for the idea that this could have
happened as I mentioned the deadline in
Wisconsin to file for the recount was
last Friday that was met the deadline in
Pennsylvania is today and the deadline
in Michigan is Wednesday so we will see
what happens in Pennsylvania and
Michigan and by the time you watching
this or listening to it depending on
which platform you're watching or
listening on we may already have news
about that and we'll talk about that
tomorrow an important issue that came up
a lot in the Facebook live feeds that
I've been doing over the weekend and by
the way check those out we answer
questions and get into a lot of detail
on some of these issues is the question
of recount versus audit recounts look at
the end of the voting process not at the
systems the procedures and the data that
got us to those final results an audit
will actually look at each transaction
that makes up the result at every step
from the initial entry of a vote to the
final result with the goal being let's
actually track each ballot individually
start to finish to use an analogy it's
sort of the difference between casting
counting votes for Trump
paired to counting attempts to vote for
Trump uh versus boats credited to trump
so it's a much deeper analysis to
actually do an audit and how ballots
were handled would be part of an audit
but not part of a recount and to give
both sides of this I I want to be super
clear and transparent there is still no
evidence that there was any fraud this
is a circumstantial case it's important
to remember that but it's important to
remember that the circumstances are very
very strange it's still more likely that
the explanation here is the polls were
wrong we have evidence of that we do not
actually have evidence at this time that
there was hacking or foul play but the
circumstances are very odd and if
there's money for a recount and Jill
Stein has raised millions of dollars if
there's demand for a recount let's do
the recount bearing in mind that really
we need an audit to uncover what's being
alleged to recount alone would would
likely not do that and I don't know you
know I see a lot of progress is getting
very excited about this and excited can
depend on whether it's because you
believe that this will change results in
a particular State or whether you
believe that there was hacking and audit
is really the way to uncover that and
that is not something that has yet
started now Donald Trump meanwhile is
claiming that there was fraud but that
it's in Hillary Clinton's uh favor he
actually tweeted he sent a string of ten
or twelve tweets yesterday about this
but the the one I want to talk about is
Donald Trump saying in addition to
winning the electoral college in a
landslide I won the popular vote if you
deduct the millions of people who voted
illegally of course there's no evidence
to support that whatsoever and Trump has
cited no evidence and by the way Trump
also didn't win the electoral college in
a landslide you might want to review the
election results from some past
elections to get some context there
Donald but how have they not taken
Twitter away from Donald Trump for good
already as a question I have and the the
the sort of most ironic thing about this
is that if what Trump says is true then
he's making the case for not only a
recount but a full audit right if Donald
Trump
is actually accurate or at least
possibly accurate and saying you know
what I won the popular vote it should be
his imperative to demand a recount and
an audit because as a result of him
losing the popular vote by more than 2
million votes it implies the biggest
anti mandate or lack of a mandate that
we've seen in a very long time if I were
Trump and I truly believe that I had won
the popular vote as he says you should
get that recount and audit going right
away although I'm gonna talk about that
a little bit later a couple other things
to mention number one if the recounts
begin and it turns out that the results
in the presidential election were
different than reported uh then we need
to look at auditing Senate races nobody
is talking about that one person
mentioned it on one of my weekend
Facebook live streams and and that is
very very important if indeed the
results I don't want to use the term
were messed with hacked whatever if the
results after a recount or ideally an
audit which I don't know that we're
going to get end up being different in
any of these presidential elections at
the state level we need to also look at
these Senate elections because that has
huge implications right now of course
republicans winning the senate and why
would we assume that if presidential
results were messed with that definitely
there's nothing to look into as far as
senate results so i think that's
something really important that's not
being mentioned in terms of the recounts
we're waiting on pennsylvania is
probably the one with the biggest
hurdles for a recount candidates cannot
directly file recount requests in
pennsylvania they can file a legal
appeal that's decided on by a court you
actually can get a statewide recount
when you get at least three voters /
precinct or election district to submit
affidavits there were over 9,000
election districts in pennsylvania as of
jun of 2015 so we will keep you posted
there please let me know your thoughts
about this on twitter at d pakman and at
david pakman show people asking me David
you don't like Jill Stein are you angry
that she's so involved in this no I'm
not angry at all i think that the
circumstances again
a circumstantial case but the
circumstances to me warrant a at I i
would say an audit but it minimum a
recount and congratulations this is the
best thing jill stein is done this
entire election cycle let me know your
thoughts on twitter at d pakman and
we'll be back after this we're starting
to get into the holiday gift-giving
phase of the year and i am not big on
the irrational purchasing of gifts that
people won't use but i'm actually going
to be giving a couple of the men that
are going to be uh receiving gifts from
me this year mvmt watches and movement
watches which i'm wearing here and i
love my movement watch uh i'm going to
be giving some of these watches as gifts
and i'm thrilled that movement watches
continues to sponsor the david pakman
show including today's episode up to get
nice clean simple design watches if you
go into a department store soften for
five hundred bucks for watches that
quite frankly I don't think are
particularly well designed uh nor are
they that well made the mvmt watches
start at ninety five bucks and you can
actually get an even bigger discount
fifteen percent off and free shipping
and free returns by going to mvmt
watches dot-com / Pakman mvmt watches
dot-com / Pakman over 500,000 watches
have now been sold by movement watches
in over a hundred and sixty countries
and that is particularly cool because
movement watches started similarly to
have the david pakman show started with
crowdfunding campaigns and sort of a
couple of guys who said hey here's an
idea let's turn it into something and
everywhere I go this watch attract
attention people say hey where'd you get
that that's really cool and when I tell
them how affordable it is they get very
very interested so go to mvmt watches
dot-com / Pakman fifteen percent off
free shipping free returns